to overtime of ramzan itis Egypt so the
priests told me was in always well
governed and greatly prospered but
Cheops who was the next king brought the
people to utter misery for first he shut
up all the temples so that none could
sacrifice there and next he compelled
all the Egyptians to work for him
appointing some to drag stones from the
quarries in the Arabian mountains to the
Nile and the stones being carried across
the river in boats others were charged
to receive and drag them to the
mountains called in Libyan they worked
in gangs of a hundred thousand men each
gang for three months for ten years the
people were afflicted in making the road
where on the stones were dragged the
making of which road was to my thinking
a task but a little lighter than the
building of the pyramid for the road is
five furlongs long and ten fathoms broad
and raised at its highest to height of
eight fathoms and it is all of stone
polished and Carvin with figurines the
ten years aforesaid went to the making
of this road and of the underground
chambers on the hill whereon the
pyramids stand these the King meant to
be burial places for himself and the
compass them with water bringing in a
channel from the Nile the pyramid itself
was twenty years in the making its base
was square each side 800 feet long and
it's height is the same the hole is of
stone polished and most exactly fitted
there is no block of less than thirty
feet in length this pyramid was made
like a stairway with tiers or steps when
this its first form was completed the
workmen used levers made of short wooden
logs to raise the rest of the stones
they heaved up the blocks from the
ground onto the first tier of steps when
the stone had been so raised it was set
on another lever that stood on the first
tier and a lever again drew it up from
this tier to the next it may be that
there was a new lever on each tier of
the steps or perhaps there was but one
leave
and that easily lifted which they
carried up to each tearing turn when
they had taken out the stone I leave
this uncertain both ways being told me
but this is certain that the upper part
of the pyramid was the first finished
off then the next below it and last of
all the base and the lowest part there
are writings on the pyramid in Egyptian
characters showing how much was spent on
purges and onions and garlic for the
workmen and so far as I well remember
the interpreter when he read me the
writing said that 1600 talents of silver
had been paid now if that is so how much
must needs have been expended on the
iron with which they worked and the
workman's food and clothing seeing that
the time aforesaid was spent in building
and the hewing and carrying of the stone
in the digging out of the underground
parts was as I suppose the business of
long duration
and so evil a man was a UPS but for lack
of money he made his own daughter to sit
in a chamber an exact payment how much I
I know not for they did not tell me this
she they say doing her father's bidding
was minded to leave some memorial of her
own and demanded of everyone who sought
intercourse with her that he should give
one stone to set in her work and of
these stones was built the pyramid that
stands mid most of the three over
against the Great Pyramid each side of
it measures 150 feet Cheops reigned so
the Egyptians said for fifty years at
his death he was succeeded by his
brother schefren who bore himself in all
respects like cherubs Chephren also
built a pyramid of less size than his
brothers I have myself measured it it
has no underground chambers nor is it
entered like the other by a canal from
the Nile but the river comes in through
a built passage and in circles an island
in which they say Cheops in self lies
this pyramid was built of the same
bigness as the other saved it falls 40
feet short of it in height it stands
near to the Great Pyramid the lowest
layer of it is variegated Ethiopian
stone both of them stand on the same
ridge which is about a hundred feet high
Chephren he said rained for 56 years
thus they reckoned that for a hundred
and six years Egypt was in great misery
and the temples so long shut were never
opened so much do the people hate the
memory of these two kings that they do
not greatly wish to name them and call
the pyramids after the Shepherd philetus
who then pastored his flocks in this
place
[Music]